welcome to the check-in it's Tuesday the
12th of September the check-in is
brought to you by freeze pipe for the
smoothest coldest way to smoke you got
to try the freezable pipe bubbler or
bong from freeze pipe here's how it
works you pop the glycerin chamber in
the freezer wait an hour and watch as
the smoke is cooled by a whopping 300
degrees no more coughing no more burning
I love the freeze pipe they just sent me
a new compartment for blunts
guys you put in the freezer you roll
your blunt you take it out of the
freezer and now the blunts won't burn
you that bad they just released a mini
bong and a tornado bong and they're not
only affordable but the punch well above
their weight class and for those who
prefer smoking joints blumps and Vapes
free freeze pipe has you covered with
that new glycerin blunt tip it brings
your icy glycerin coldness when smoking
any type of joint blunt or vape say
goodbye to hard smoke and coughing
attacks by sharpening in the smoothest
pipes bubblers and buns and dab rigs at
thefreeze pipe.com and use code Diaz
Diaz for ten percent off your entire
order that's thefreeze pipe.com code
Diaz Diaz for 10 off shop today and
start smoking like you live in an aspen
the chicken is also brought to you by
Babel listen if you're headed to a
different country you need to pack
Babble in your suitcase Joey what's
Babble Babble is a real language
learning for real conversations you can
start speaking a new language in just
three weeks with that new fun 10-minute
sessions how great is that now you can
talk to people in different languages
who's better than you the program is
designed by over 150 language experts
with a conversation Based Teaching model
you'll be learning things you actually
need to know for real life situations
like where is the bus
stuff like that instead of fooling
yourself with language apps that are
little more than games choose Babel b a
b b e l a study even found that you was
in Babel for just 15 hours is equivalent
to a full semester in college how's that
one for you here's a special limited
time for our listeners to get get
started get 55 off again
55 off Babel subscription but only for
our listeners at babel.com
Joey again that's babble.com Joey get 55
off at babel.com
Joey spell Babble
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Joey without
further Ado let's get this party started
I love your TVs run for your lives it's
over they didn't put you on this planet
just to give up if Uncle Joey could do
it I could rule the world I feel
you got to be thinking
[Music]
oh oh
there he is
[Laughter]
not smoke cause it's uh September 11th
my heart goes out to everybody 22 years
later it's still a disaster but
we're still back you know what I'm
saying we're still kicking ass America
what's up Lee Syed I'm ready to go I'm
ready for the checking I'm ready to go
you didn't take an edible yet I'm it's
right here see this is everyone says I
don't take you're making those fake
ones I listen to it
think think
what's up buddy how was your weekend my
weekend was great you didn't do no stand
up right
unfortunately not unfortunately not
what is your next little hoopty
Loop this weekend this weekend uh Friday
and Saturday I'm at the Saratoga Comedy
Works
that's how we do it brother oh yeah and
then next week
huh go ahead I'm sorry sorry next week
I'm at uh the Chicopee comedy Loft on
Thursday look at you you bad
that's right the New York
to how to LA to Reno back to the ghetto
someday I love it brother look at you
International Lee Syed starting this
tour in Battlefield Israel
oh they would hate me in Israel they'd
like you more than they like me I'm like
a Jew that went bad but the Cubans like
you more than they like me so it all
works out for the better how's the
girlfriend how's the kids everybody
jumping up and down everyone's doing
everyone's doing great it's been fun
like her with the kids I love I was
thinking about this do you love pissing
Mercy off
not really no I love pissing okay
you know I torture a little bit
you know I do things that bother a
little bit but I don't push the issue
too much every once in a while I scare
you know how do you scare you just
stand outside the door when she
comes up always I got different masks
and oh yeah like a voodoo mess he
brought back from Colombia he always
brings me a mask from these places to
fight the demons you know what I'm
saying oh my God I love I like I like to
tell them like I'm Taylor Swift's best
friend
and they freak out
then you call me up like I'm Taylor
Swift
Taylor Swift you
oh I love doing it so football
season I was working alive man thank God
and it was a hell of a week so
far I mean
I turned it around I started the week
off with Detroit just took a chance with
it because
what the and then
before you get to Sunday
you gave me for Saturday and I
wanted to defend myself what should
forsake because I don't know anything
about college football but I'm trying
you know I'm trying to have some fun
betting I'm trying to have something to
talk about and I had a random I had an
odd number in my account I had 143. I
hate I don't like odd numbers so I
placed a 13 bet
and you gave me for like 30 minutes
what's wrong I don't know anything about
the game you don't ever place like a 10
BET what's wrong with the 30 it was
thirteen fifteen dollars first off
you're Jewish no Jewish man gets annoyed
by those three pennies okay
I don't know what kind of Jew you are 43
cents is 43 cents okay and you
hold on to it 13 how do you end up with
it listen
you bet Colorado you think I know about
college football I know dick about
college football I know that the
excitement is great up in Colorado yeah
you know so I had nothing to lose they
were playing in Boulder on a
beautiful goddamn day that's the Lord's
country right now did Denver win on
Sunday
no they lost we're at home or away
I don't know the I think they were I
think they were home you know it's weird
when Denver plays at home and they got a
good team one o'clock game the Lord's
day I don't give a if you show up
with Jesus and the disciples and Pontius
Pilate you're not beating the I
lived there for 20 years you
know what this reminded me of you
remember the the you where you said the
Miami players were more and more popular
than the Dolphins players I think that's
what's going on in in two weeks with
Colorado over the bro I don't think I
know they like the Broncos but people
hate Russell Wilson
and I think I think they I think they
love me on Sanders well Colin listen uh
Boulder I worked at a car wash and there
were huge donors
they went to every game they went to the
Orange Bowl they went to practices you
know the more money you give
the more you hang out I mean if you pay
2 000 you cut the football players
toenails if you want money for anything
those boosters and I I never
seen that before
like when I lived in Boulder I had never
seen people that didn't have kids on the
team
who traveled with the team and like went
to all their functions and it was pretty
good to see the old me would have said
it was kind of geeky right no it's it's
it's nice that's what they were into
some people smoke dope some people want
to go watch college football games so
I don't know much about college but I
know
Colorado is a beautiful cow
Boulder is phenomenal I want to take my
daughter now just to open her eyes
just so she could see
what the I'm gonna take her then to
Vanderbilt when I go to Nashville next
time for the holidays
just so you know because nobody ever
took us when we were in high school or
the eighth grade or the fifth grade and
showed us what life could be like this
is a University
you know and then they'll take you to
like
Boston City College and it's like in in
Southie you know the admissions office
has no teeth
you go in there and Southie the guy
drinking with a cigarette in his house
with a no smoking sign right behind him
he don't give a and he's talking to
you with the cigarette in his hand and
so yeah that's the reason I went with
Colorado
because because of Boulder being a
pretty place no because Boulder just has
a weird energy
and Dion brought even a weirder energy
yeah Beyond brought a winning energy and
he's fired up and he got the town fired
up
like like it was the most expensive
ticket this week uh Nebraska Colorado
how does he do that in two weeks
that's crazy and this is a
motivator
he used to motivate himself to be the
best every Sunday and then he'd take a
helicopter and go play baseball you know
I mean uh whether he was an All-Star or
not or whatever he still did that
and he's one of those guys he's just a
winner dog
his his energy
beats everything you know
his energy and his likeness
he wants to play us to have fun
I finally realized at the age of 55 or
something that I could save everybody's
energy with as you get older if you're
not having fun get the out of there
that's hard though like a lot of people
don't have fun at their jobs or in life
no they don't and they don't want to
have fun at work and you have to kind of
create that environment if they fire you
go to the next job
but it's so weird how
people just don't have that energy
anymore I see it
and my daughter's softball teams and the
other teams are they coaching when my
daughter's team is happy and they're
giggling they're doing their little
cheers and they're hitting the back of
their legs and they're winning
they're hitting home runs they're
hitting doubles but when they're like
doomed about something it's all over the
shop
when you go on stage
Your Enthusiasm is what makes them laugh
everybody got jokes everybody got jokes
Your Enthusiasm
is what makes them laugh
how long did it take you
to be able to like turn off what's going
on in your life before you went on stage
like if you're having a shitty day or
you got a flat tire on the way there
five years really four years
four years of well the toughest thing
was like I said
uh a thousand times that I I trained
myself to drop my daughter off and I'd
cry in the car
I pick myself up I'd smoke a joint and I
forced myself not to go home
I would shoot out to do comedy out of
any
any I would go to that place
with the fat Pizza Guy the Elvis
impersonator I was feeling bad about
myself when I walked in there I felt
even worse about myself but in the
through the night I catch myself and go
Joey you're doing stand up yeah
that's the most important thing you know
I still remember Landing in Vegas and
getting a call that Brody died
you know go to a show for 2 000 people
you know
I can't but I mean I canceled because
Brody no I love Brody but I gotta go do
a performance for Brody now I gotta
perform for Brody One Last Time mention
him in the set tell a brody story and I
make my piece you know how do you
I'm so in like people come up to me like
oh I like your style you you're so
monotone and quiet you can't make them
listen I don't it's just who I'm so
jealous of people who have like energy
like that did you have to like train
yourself to have energy yeah because if
you're a dud they're gonna be a
dud
I think I'm gonna die I I I I I I try to
like hang myself up but uh energy is uh
there's kinetic and potential energy
okay there's two types of energy energy
emotion and energy that's stored
I could be standing like a mummy
you know like you hit me with a
uh gun or something right you're
standing there but for some reason the
way I move my hips
without moving my hips my shoulders your
hands when you're driving on the highway
what do you see windmills okay windmills
windmills windmills they create energy
that's why I never touched a microphone
oh the weather's hand
and I go up there and I make sure I'm
talking to them the way I be talking to
a cop
oh I didn't know nothing that's why
I don't touch the microphone because
that's energy from your hands you're
creating energy
those two minutes before you go on stage
your potential energy
you're just standing behind that
burning what if I borrow what if I step
on a banana peel what if my mother well
you know it's like what if I forget that
joke you know and and then you go up
there
you touch the mic and the energy
connects now you have to go into kinetic
energy
so like I said even if I stand there
like when I started listen I
experimented with everything right so I
used to do the Eddie Murphy thing walk
back and forth
really
like you know somewhere in my first four
years I made it a habit to walk back and
forth
and that didn't work for me
it kind of did but it didn't
you know I started making eye contact
started connecting with individual
people
and then
from there you grow and you grow you
know it's it's getting on stage that's
it
there's no book I wish I could
sell you a book that would make you
better
me too getting on stage
every day when you have an
opportunity is it I'm talking if there's
no stage time going to a movie theater
and going up there and doing four
minutes and getting thrown out but
laughing your ass off and even putting
having your friends over Graham and see
security chase you out and you know
that that's you put that on YouTube
that's two million views you know what
I'm saying oh yeah absolutely train
yourself to do all these weird things I
used to do karaoke and the guy didn't
want us to do comedy so we would have to
write the song give it to him and then
go up there and fluctuation let me talk
to people about something
[Music]
I can't and that's it's just
I
like oh you know what when you're
talking about energy and I know it's I
think it's energy the thing that like
you do probably as well or better than
anybody is laughing on stage
there's something about laughing on
stage and I don't know if I'm too
focused on my stuff and I do it
occasionally like after we recorded last
week I went to an open mic high as
and I giggled the entire time I was on
stage but how do you like that what do
you think about that like how hard is it
to laugh at your stuff
I can't fake laugh right all right
the time I laugh is when I improvise a
joke
when I improvise a joke that I haven't
even thought of and it comes out right
there uh-huh and I giggle about it like
that's when I
that's when I laugh but you laugh your
entire you must improvise every goddamn
thing no because I'm looking at people
looking at their faces when I say
you know it's just uh I don't know it's
something about I can't fake laugh I'm
not a fake laugh I don't sit in the back
that's not me that you hear on the
uh
what's his name a guy on HBO there's
that guy that has the show gilmar yeah
Bill Maher I love Bill Maher but when
he's got a guy on the show that just
sits in the back and laughs loud I
wonder if they give him like the small
15K yeah just come to six episodes and
laugh the loudest and he always goes
to a comedy club and somebody cracks a
joke
two idiots in the back are like oh yeah
what are you doing like we're trying to
support you're not if I'm on stage and
you make that noise all I can pray for
is a Chinese dark
like a blowing you like a you
know
there on the other side of that though
and I don't know about you but like I we
connected early on because I love albums
like I love comedy CDs
for some reason and even when I had a
show if they're and I don't know why it
is if there's a woman that I can hear
her laugh specifically it doesn't have
to be any just a female laugh that is
like consistent throughout the show
it's like some of the best I don't know
what it is I feel like a woman laughing
make my entire
I don't know why I can just hear it do
you ever like hone in on a specific
laugh when you're on stage there's
certain ladies that laugh there's
certain people that don't get out much
and when they go out they love
to laugh and
that's it's a tennis match comedy is a
tennis match my joke that you'll laugh
my joke to your left my joke to you it
don't work like that all the time right
yeah one-way Street you know what I'm
saying you just hitting the
tennis balls and nobody's doing
like when all my tennis balls go oh you
suck Joey
but the other dad did something pretty
insane since you're talking
about
one of my favorite bits in comedy I mean
I could see why he blew up
from that bit
which one like there's people who blow
up from specials
there's people who blow up for many
reasons a movie a a TV show
I like when people blow up because of
the gift of Comedy like they're that
good you know you didn't have to use
MySpace or nothing like that or Twitter
or Instagram
and I think Cat Williams Michael Jackson
joke yeah is one of the greatest jokes
of all time because it's a black man
bashing a black man in front of a black
audience and the response is just oohs
and eyes
you know I don't know what my point was
here but uh you were just saying like
the like a bit that you like one of your
favorite bits of all time and like I
laugh so I had it in the car the other
day Okay I was listening to Richard
Pryor in the car Mercy was with me oh
about my Apple
so for some reason Richard Pryor went
into
nut it went into Katt Williams
doing the Michael Jackson bit
and he you know he transitions it
perfectly he talks about Martha Stewart
going to prison
for transferring money right he talks
about little Kim going to prison for not
ratting and then he goes meanwhile
Michael Jackson is running loose
when mercy heard that because one of her
best friends is a big Michael Jackson
a face
she was like Dad I go yeah listen to it
he comes back because it like connects
tracks you track you know you hear it go
down then it and he just goes off on
Michael Jackson poor little Mercy was
petrified you thought I was doing 150
miles an hour in the car she was just
pressed against the thing listening and
just shaking her head little little
boy's booty holes I lost it I
had to explain to her later on that you
know he got accused and he had to pay
the small 20 million
I know she likes Michael Jackson so I
didn't break up balls that way do you
introduce what's that oh I'm sorry you
wanna talk about football no no what
were you saying I was just gonna say do
you show her a lot of Comedy
no but one of her friends told about the
Tom Segura bit
okay oh yeah and what did she think
of that
I don't know I don't know if she saw it
you know it says that I did heroin for
20 years that's the last thing I wanted
to see I didn't do heroin for 20 years
right yeah I am the
Tom Segura killer the ABX 200 milligram
oh yeah these are the best they
really are
they really
love it you bothering me all right
there you go all right
so what were your uh did you look at
next week's I did and there's a few
different games
um so
and I don't know why but right now
Kansas City Jacksonville is like very
close like Kansas City's favor
but I just like I just saw right before
we started that uh the guy like the
defensive player Chris Jones who was
holding out just signed so he should be
back and I don't know if Travis Kelsey's
are coming back but if Travis Kelsey
comes back and Chris Jones is back I
think Kansas City
is gonna destroy Jacksonville especially
after losing like embarrassingly the
week before I think they'll do pretty
well right now it's minus 155 so it's
not like crazy it's not like minus 600
or something
so I like that one a lot
um I think Detroit's gonna beat Seattle
and that they're favored by five and a
half I never bet I I hate points I
always just bet if they're gonna win or
they're gonna lose
but then also
Baltimore versus Cincinnati
Baltimore is the underdog they won last
week and Cincinnati got destroyed and I
know Cincinnati probably doesn't want to
get
embarrassed again
but Baltimore is giving three and a half
points so that's something that I don't
like if I think someone might lose but
it's going to be a close game
that's when I'm like okay I'll give the
plus points okay some of these lines are
created
to make you jump on it okay so right now
you're a regular American Mama Luke
right I'm gonna put it better next week
on whatever the right I
have no idea who you're talking about
I'm not talking about you I'm just
talking about them
not you no seriously I know I know I
know you're not General Public
all right because this is who you're
learning from the general public and
what they like so next week let's look
at a game like Cincinnati Bengals
Baltimore Ravens you're absolutely right
they got embarrassed last week
Cincinnati I could not believe
how great Cleveland looked that's forget
about that Cleveland's got their number
Cincinnati did not look good I like them
I I really like to see that dude Joe
Burrows he's great they're playing a
Baltimore team that covered the 12th so
I went down to nine and a half
they uh
they covered the spread
so right now everybody in America is
going
I'm taking Baltimore getting three and a
half right that's what I would do and
the smart move there I think
Cincinnati will beat him by three
and you've got the hook right that's
from or
I would watch this line during the week
okay I would watch this line during the
week There's a couple great games
but if you sell
you know tell them what we saw last week
tell them what we learned last week
Saturday night out of Sanyo was fighting
Strickland okay I did not watch
the fight
I didn't like the card that much I
didn't feel like going 80 bucks for the
car I know and I don't even stay
up that late she comes down at midnight
to watch The Honeymooners on Saturday
night that means the the the
uh thing is not good for me yeah
the main event watch it she wants to
watch The Honeymooners saw we got a
couple TVs but that don't matter she
wants to want to watch The Honeymooners
down here
so I wasn't even thinking about the
fight to be honest with you I didn't
even know there was a fight on Saturday
night yeah they didn't really promote it
but I got
I I thought I thought for sure Israel
was going to win well let's go back to
the Basics here what ended up
happening
the line opened up at like Israel you
made three bucks if you bet Israel right
right and all of a sudden sadly at three
o'clock what happened on DraftKings they
had that promo what was the promo plus I
think it was plus 100
profit boost
so you you need to tell me that you went
from me betting fifty dollars and
winning 750 you know if I bet fifty
dollars I get fifty dollars now yeah
we're going dollar for dollar this is
better the bookmaker from the
diner you know what I'm saying this is
better than anything
everybody jumped on that bet yeah
okay me too
and then I saw people like uh Chael
Sonnen a couple people Fighters were
saying
who's not going to bet Israel this on
you like that was the main theme like
you know this is going to be a
punch in the head now did I send you the
the text with the bet no what I bet 25
bucks on Strickland no of course you
didn't because I put the Bet On It
I put it for Israel and I lost you never
sent me the beds when they win I was
going to bet Israel but I said there's
got to be something going on here
something ain't right you've never seen
a bookie with a part-time job plus you
have so much action this week
you had College you had Thursday night
you got baseball yeah and right now it's
like everybody's getting ready for
playoffs so these
are playing all right
you had a full card
on Sunday and then another card on
Monday night which is going to be a
heavy duty bet game next this tonight's
game right it's going to be one of the
biggest bet games ever
it said 50 50 right now nobody can make
a pick you know I'm saying I mean
tonight you pick this to watch the game
and enjoy it
whether it's raining like hell in Jersey
and so the under could be it so Betty
over
because of the weather
you know like this you know like
this is what you have to look at
plus it's a Monday night game
Monday nights people put in parlays they
love it Monday nights that's what you
call it the Monday night parlay nobody
sells a Monday night side everybody
sells a Monday night ballet
so one of those sides is going to be
up it's like the other night with
Detroit
right what happened with that one
well I think the line was four and a
half okay probably and something was it
Detroit it was somebody else
I forget who the it was that did a
move like that anyway I'm stoned and the
ABX isn't kicking in Jack
oh yeah do you ever bet like crazy
like I I know you don't like tennis but
like the US Open do you ever put
anything on something you just have no
idea about it I just be donating money
through a homeless guy and give him the
small plenty because I don't know I
don't bet like most people because I
don't know a lot about
who's the new quarterback you know I
don't pay attention to that I'm
looking at the line
I'm looking at the goddamn line so
you know this week I had like I said I
had Jacksonville
I had Miami because I went to Jimmy's I
didn't have them big 25 bucks I think he
won 47.
and I had uh New England
and see it wasn't it was three and a
half so I was hoping I wouldn't with the
hook
right yeah and and do you what do you do
more of before the game or in-game
betting I'm gonna tell you something
I love this new sports betting this new
everybody's doing it the DraftKings live
betting for me yesterday I who could
tolerate that Giant game no one
after three minutes they were down 16
nothing I knew what time it was I ran I
did something I went to like CVS or
something
and then I came back and it was still
like they look like bet I know a
high school team that could beat
the Giants
and I bet the under
and I started watching winning time with
the Lakers with my wife and then mercy
came down we're talking when they went
upstairs I went to check and it was 40
or nothing
and the second string
quarterback got put in I'm like
that's 11 points that's a these guys
could throw two I was two touchdowns
away from losing but I ended up winning
I woke up this morning and uh the game
had gone under
so listen it's a 50 50 toss-up
it's just fun it's entertaining you
throw a little something small on the
game just to enjoy it I got some rice
pudding from the Manalapan diner
for late night like the fourth quarter
you know the edible will kick in that's
all this is entertainment I go to bed I
get up and tomorrow you hustle again
that's basically it my friend
I would love I was thinking about this
because I'm a fat guy how much money do
you think like pizza places make on a
Sunday like now in football season they
must love it I was like it was
packed to my surprise crispy pizza the
official new sponsor to the check-in God
damn right we hold the 1-0 bridge had a
fire
but the one in Freehold is good
yeah you know what time they were opened
on Saturday night
what time midnight oh that's the best
that means you can run that air and be
back at my house by 11 30 by the co-ed
line fight
I love can you imagine you always get
the pizza at 11 15 at night when you're
stoned on these abx's
and also you got something to watch for
two hours and you just devour that P I
haven't done it in years I can't eat a
whole pizza I ate two slices and it's
busted out of me man love it though
I got you know for a while I
came here and I wasn't eating pizza and
I was depressed I was like kind of
them I eat pizza I used to eat one slice
a day what it all tasted the same to me
and then I walked into crispy and it
changed my life I still got I
like my regulars I like
uh you know the one I took you to the
Staten Island people right those in
there all the time we got pies I haven't
been in there in a while I gotta go in
there and say hello Carlos Carlos is my
boy you know John Leona
and uh I go to a couple you know
it's not like I'm gonna drive like
the dude from
bar stool I'm not driving two hours to
go get a slice of pizza I got good food
right around here but it was crazy
tonight with that beef stew I've been
craving beef stew
yeah isn't it hot though it's like
aren't you isn't it too hot for beef
stew
not tonight not in Joey Diaz's world
Jesus I'm white trash I could always eat
beef stew I could eat a can of denti
more
like a I love denty more
can't Stewart with Wonder bread with
butter on that come on you
know the farts you'll be blowing at
midnight you eat one of those artificial
Russian carrots
you might lose your eyesight grip
my you might have 40 40 Vision
instead well is it a Russian carrot yeah
those little they buy those carrots from
Russia Ukraine you know those are
supposed to be a Carriage that
I went on a
I'm definitely gonna get thrown in jail
for this one
real presenting Danny Masterson thing
Jesus Christ I'm just how many years did
he get
30.
that's crazy it's
it's crazy that someone can get away
with it for that long hold on one second
with that in mind now for a word for my
sponsors
all right football's in full swing with
another week of epic game and to the
excitement with DraftKings an official
sports betting partner of the NFL new
customers you hear it all low but now
you're hearing it from my Uncle Joey
that's five dollars on football to get
200 instantly on bonus bets take
advantage of two new offers every single
game this September getting on the NFL
week two action with DraftKings
Sportsbook download the app now and use
code Joey to sign up only at DraftKings
Sportsbook the crown is yours again five
dollars and get 200 an instant bonus
bets and it's not just the bets guys
it's the the website everything that
they do the happy hours like I said
Saturday night they offered a hundred
percent boost for the fight this is the
type of stuff they do so do me a favor
download the app and use code Joey if
you got a gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler or visit www dot 1-800
gambler.net on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort
see
sportsbook.draftkings.com football again
download the app use code Joey let's
make the game more exciting you're
watching it with family you want to jump
up and down the check-in is also brought
to you by better help the next time you
want to shop your troubles away eat your
feelings or drink your Sorrows turn to
Better Health their online therapy that
gives you a place to express your
emotions and work through your problems
and make important decisions with
guidance better help is entirely online
and is designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
getting started is very easy just fill
out a brief questionnaire get matched up
with a licensed therapist and you could
switch therapists at any time at no
additional charge listen
how's it better help for about a year I
was going through a bunch of stuff and
they really bailed me out
and now I got a clear head so you too
can head into the fall season with a
clear coconut get a break from your
thoughts with better help again visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz today to get 10 off your first
month that's
betterhelp.com
Diaz we're back all right we're talking
about Danny Masterson
yeah I was just saying like it's I I to
be honest dude that stuff is depressing
so I didn't I didn't look too heavily
into but I have seen what's going on
with his friends who wrote letters and
he's got he like
so many years it's crazy
yeah
God I'm sorry just how long he like you
get away with it for that whole thing is
just
you have this image of people because
that 70s Show when I was growing up was
big that was a big show
very big
the problem is here it wasn't
I don't think the conviction wasn't yet
Danny Masterson as much as a conviction
about scientology
the reason why it took 20 years to
prosecute because Scientology was hiding
and Hauling and you know whatever the
they do torment people and whatever
so it took a while to get some traction
to it
you know the D.A must have heard some
stories or something and they just went
in there and listen man like you said
I got to LA in 97.
I booked a couple jobs 98 then I went on
the road I didn't book for a couple
years
and then like in 2001 I started booking
and I'll never forget
being on a pilot I was on a show that
got canceled on NBC and it had all these
young little hipster stars and I had a a
two-day
guest star on it or some I did two
episodes
but the young kids on that the people
who were on that show
between you and I you know I'm as tough
as nails
they made you feel insecure
about what because they were always like
telling Secrets amongst themselves
they were very cutesy like it was all a
joke
and then years later I did How I Met
Your Mother mm-hmm
and I'll never forget how those little
acted you know I mean they were
like little they were like little
girls
and the guy that's on the Lakers show
who I like on the Laker show you know
he's a great actor Jason Siegel he was
the ringleader and they really seen when
I was shooting that they threw a balloon
at somebody
it was supposed to be like a balloon I'm
throwing to you
through it at the assistant just for a
joke and there she is covered with water
she had tears in her eyes and he turned
around to the other little nerdy
and they were like giggle like we did it
you know
so I want you to understand the
mentality of these little
scumbags okay what they would do and now
it's starting to come out that they were
going to kiss a 14 year old girl
whatever I don't you know it's Hollywood
what the do you expect
but these guys
uh they did what they wanted to
you know Toby Maguire and those animals
were taking people playing poker
that young crew was death
you know uh Leonardo DiCaprio with the
poker games and the and the
and the 70s Show was part of
that those guys you know the little
Mexican guy that slings dick like three
hands the Honduran kid
you know but those other guys I could
see them as like being kind of cutesy in
fact I thought about a show I did called
happy hour
I did a pilot for Fox about 10 years ago
even longer 15 years ago it was either
out of all those people in that pilot
one person Giant
two of them really John and this other
guy that was on narcos he had tons of
movie roles the other guys were stiffs
they all came they were done by the it
was the show done by the same people as
the 70s Show okay when they wrapped the
70s Show this is the show they developed
called happy hour
they had fired when I went in for that
job they had fired the previous four
people before me
not for your role not two not three four
because it was a funny role
these guys were improv
they know nothing about being funny all
they know about is how to be funny with
eight people on stage right right for a
bunch of Americans you know oh
my god get the out of here I want
to see you go down to a brick wall with
a microphone and fight it out
okay
what was I talking about about the show
happy hour you were the fourth one for
your role I was the fifth guy that got
hired fifth one and after that fox was
like no no more
and I went in there and tore them up I
called them up dog
you know I had a couple lines but I
improvised and I used my body or
whatever and I tore them up and after
two days they were ganging up on me
little secrets and oh them we
shot the pilot everything was successful
they didn't like me I was in a different
realm I'm a comedy store Soldier I'm a
marine these guys are that you
know they're paying 800 a month for
somebody to tell them they're funny you
know two different worlds my
friend
how is
go ahead I'm sorry I was just saying how
was acting because I know you said like
you have like the the stand-up chops but
how is it different does it feel similar
to be funny acting as it does look when
you're on stage
it takes some time it takes time to
learn because you're so stiff at first
and listen I've seen people who have
done it there's some actors who were
great first time movies and it took
me a while to get a little warmed up you
know I didn't know what I was doing I
got picked right out of the choir for
basketball I was just walking by with a
red shirt on that people thought it was
like a whistle
but uh
you know you just I didn't get my full
stride till Marc Maron show
really yeah I started to be honest The
Longest Yard developed it right 17
weeks
so that's like every week doing
10 sets boom boom doing two two scenes a
day you know four days a week
and then 17 times you know that's a lot
of scenes so you learn you just that was
a great movie for me
because I practiced every day
do you think
because like my least favorite part and
I love doing weekends but I hate Late
Show Saturday because I'm like I don't
I'm not at the point here where I'm
doing it every week if and I know with
the longest yard you thought like it
might have like catapulted to do like a
lot of acting if you had gone from like
the longest yard and did movie and movie
like do you think there could have been
a point where you would have stopped
doing stand-up and just been an actor
I don't know Lee
I don't know at when I got the longest
yard I love doing stand-up I was just
breaking into who I was
so it was very interesting for me I
remember not doing stand up the first
six weeks
in Santa Fe and like looking for open
mics and then I just used the set I
would just go off on the set
but those were the roughest six weeks
for me ever
and I didn't also do below those six
weeks
so there was no blow and no
stand up I would smoke dope and hang out
with the guys and crack jokes
but it was very unique for me you know
2004 I still love stand up like a
I was doing oh you know I appreciate it
going out because you were going to do
Coke after your stand-up set you know I
really enjoyed it in fact I was thinking
about today somebody put a flyer for an
open mic
on my Twitter timeline oh yeah it's in
Clifton it's a hour away an hour
back the skies are coming down here
tonight plus we had this and other
things
but uh
what we talking about about uh acting
when you were on the longest yard no con
no comments you still loved it it sucked
yeah you know I love stand up at that
time I still do
I still do I just I don't want to really
go out right now I'm having a good time
hanging out doing a podcast with you I'm
good oh yeah no it's completely
different
but I don't think so in fact I didn't
like those people
might be as honest I can with you I
didn't like people who
except for like Eddie Murphy I saw that
but I also saw a lot of stand-ups I
worked with that moved to LA and became
something else
at first I didn't appreciate it I
thought they gave up but then I realized
that stand up is just a starting point
does it have to be could you make a
career as just a stand-up
yeah
but I'm talking about a starting point
like listen
if you come to me tomorrow and go Joey I
got to be honest with you I really want
to get into the business
what should I do I really like directing
I would say to you sign up for a course
somewhere you know there's got to be
something available
and I want you to do me a favor before
you do anything get on stage one time
you think everyone should get on stage
if they're going to get into the
entertainment business okay
because it gives you a little a
different look of the field
now you know how the peasants feel down
below because we're the worker bees you
know what I'm saying
we're the worker bees we're down there
making honey all day
then as you have you know you get older
to a producer you become but I want
every listen one of the best directors I
worked with
was great because he had done stand up
for 15 years and he told me because I
wasn't a good stand-up
but now I get high constantly as a
director from the death the depth the
levels that it gave me you know so it's
interesting
it is it's interesting because stand up
even from My Level really I guess has a
little bit of everything because when
you look at a special even says written
by produced by directed by a lot of
times it's just a comic because you're
writing your whole thing you have to
like I mean the choreograph it sounds
stupid but a lot of comics have like
they walk around they have physical
jokes it's a it is a little bit of
everything
that's the gift of being a comic that
not a lot of people understand
we do it all
we run the show
and I'm very proud of that quality I am
the Captain Kirk I am the CEO
of Joey Diaz Inc you are the Captain
Kirk the CEO of Lee sciatic
what's that what's that mean Joey what's
that mean that
this is your world
it has no boundaries it has no limits
and nobody could tell you how you do it
so when you fail you fail on your own
and you get stronger
right but then that's also like a
frustrating part because
there's no like there's a path but not
really everyone's different there's no
way like if you do this and do well here
you'll get the spot here it's just all
maybe like the Booker's not even there
they're not paying attention or what
like it just that's fine you gotta
listen it doesn't feel fine
you got on stage the hooker he
didn't see you he'll see you next time
and next time you'll be a lot funnier
do you follow me right now you're using
them and they're pretty much using you
okay they I want you to think that they
re you know when you walk in we're so
happy to see you welcome they don't give
a Frenchman's God with a missing
eye on an eye patch and they would have
said you know it's it's
I don't ever want you to lose sight of
what you're doing right now with the
fourth fifth year you're just trying to
get on stage right never mind what this
guy thinks if the owner's not watching
them there's a comic that's
watching
and he's going that guy's pretty
funny I'm gonna ask him if he wants to
do next Tuesday night at the
challenge monk you know
first time I got on stage some guy came
up to me he's like hey man you want to
do Denver Broncos training camp tomorrow
night Thursday night
first time I got on stage was Tuesday
and this has given me a gig
for five bucks on Thursday
I'm sure he made ten thousand dollars it
was the Denver Broncos training camp
I was just happy to do it for five
dollars of gas money that guy ended up
giving me thousands of dollars over the
years
so that five dollar gig
my second night getting on stage led to
this guy in fact we've been talking on
Facebook lately
oh really he yeah he's still doing
comedy shows no no he's like a teacher
now he was all he owned like a
motorcycle shop
and uh he booked these great
rooms in places where there was no other
entertainment
yeah I love those places those are my
favorite places to do stand up right now
old town was out oh I love it
Town comes out and they think you're a
movie star that's when they come up to
you and they go can I touch you I never
touched the Jew before
in Portland this is a hundred percent a
true story
I was with my new boss
and you know not everyone not all the
time but every couple of weeks someone
will know me from the podcast
so I was sitting there having dinner
with my new boss was like my first time
meeting him
and I see this like Mom and kid looking
at me and it just it looks you can tell
us they look happy so they come up and
in my head I'm like oh I'm gonna look
like a I'm looking a little cool in
front of my new boss
and the mom goes you know we love your
stuff you're so funny it's like thank
you thing that means a lot and the kids
like yeah yeah you're great and they go
right before can we take a picture I
said sure and they go you know Mall Cop
is our favorite movie
Paul Blart Mark and I said and I might I
felt like I wanted to like melt into the
ground
they thought it was Kevin James I told
I'm like I'm not
I'm sorry I'm not Kevin James and they
go we don't care can we still take the
picture it's mother and son night and I
I didn't know I took a picture
with someone they thought because I
looked like Kevin James
it's one of the most it was one of the
most depressing moment because I thought
I was getting recognized uh in front of
my boss
and called me Kevin James I just said
Mall Cop
that is one of the worst oh my God I'm
getting I'm sweating just thinking about
it like Jerry's Deli in Beverly Hills
had to be 15 years ago he was on top of
the world Ralphie May and we get out of
the car and the guy runs up and goes
fluffy it's good to see you oh my God
that poor Ralphie I thought he was going
to melt into the floor that
night when people mistake you and
like that look at me for years everybody
came up to me as big that was when
I take it sometimes I said no but
sometimes they're like hey you want a
gram of blood we love you on HBO
yeah and like that was being on The
Sopranos and if you want to rock I
rock with you you know it was one of my
favorite moments with you
remember when we went to Austin once and
they put you in the wrong Hotel they put
you in the nice hotel instead of the one
by the restaurant
and we went to eat and we went to a
convenience store to get like a soda or
something in this little mall and it's
called The Domain in Austin
and there's the two guys who ran the
convenience store like oh man we
love The Sopranos you're like that's not
um that's not me guys and they're like
oh they're like oh come on we know what
you don't you don't got to be like that
and you're like guys it's not me and
after like the fourth or fifth time God
I finally went okay
and they like they like they would not
take no for an answer
they were convinced it was big
brother what are you gonna do let's look
at some games for next week
let's do it buddy
let's see what you got on top here
I'm going with Kansas City I think
because I don't I don't and I and I know
this isn't a thing okay
let's go with Minnesota against
Philadelphia I know you have Minnesota
last week I did have Minnesota we're
part of your 18th theme parlay seven
yeah I I think Philly's gonna kill is
gonna beat him
by seven no no that see that I don't
like that I don't know
I think I think I think Philly
because they they know I think that they
could have very easily lost that game
with the Patriots last night
they could have
so who do you like
I like Philly
me I don't like this game by Thursday
hopefully I'll feel the over and under
but right now I'm not feeling it
Sunday September 17th the month is
moving
it is it's crazy the Jaguars
given getting three points from Kansas
City
yeah I don't like I I like Kansas City
in that me I like Jacksonville Jaguars
you think so I'll tell you why
after the Giants won one year
the next year they opened up their
season open and they lost
the following week a bunch of guys where
I worked
got a bunch of money on the Giants
because they say there's no way the
Super Bowl champions are going to lose
two in a row and they lost two in a row
so I'm going with Jacksonville for this
one I like that game a lot
the next game is Detroit
Seattle Seahawks yeah
at the game right now I like Detroit
like I said last week listen Detroit
they're Relentless they play till the
last whistle is blown and even then you
better get ready to rock so
that's a good game you got Tennessee
against the Chargers the Chargers coming
off a loss
against Miami and uh Tennessee coming
with the new quarterback Tennessee
you know they went to like 19
quarterbacks or seven years or something
like that do you mean Indiana in
Indianapolis no Tennessee or maybe it
wasn't Indianapolis yeah yeah because
Tennessee has uh Tannehill but yeah that
new quarterback for the for the uh for
the Colts looks pretty good they look
pretty good next game you got you got
Baltimore Ravens plus three and a half
yeah that's against Cincinnati Bengals
I'm gonna wait on that game
to see where the line goes by the end of
the week it might drop to three and a
half might drop to three or go up to
four
do you ever play with that because on
DraftKings you can do that you can make
your own odds
and like with the line a little bit
on DraftKings yeah you can go in and be
like I think the over under is going to
be this and it'll affect the payout the
payout yeah I saw that but you can make
your own odds
Green Bay came out throwing some Heat
yesterday yeah Jordan love that's I
think that's the way to do it you have a
quarterback like understudy like the
last three Green Bay Packers
quarterbacks and I know it's only been
one game but he looked really
good how did Atlanta do yesterday
I think they I think they lost but let
me check
let's see here
are you
oh
yeah no uh no they beat Carolina okay
that's Carolina right there both of them
won yesterday Green Bay had a good day
I don't know what to do that I don't
know much about these teams Tampa Bay
Chicago Bears Tampa Bay won yesterday
right yeah Tom Brady no yeah Baker
Mayfield look good I think and I like
the Bears I like the Bears a lot but
based on yesterday I think Tampa Bay
would win that one
okay yeah they still
you think Tampa Bay yeah I started in
Tampa Bay
Buffalo and the Raiders in Buffalo first
uh Sunday game at home
you know it's nice weather up there the
pierogies are cooking
eating wings with blue cheese like it's
going out of business here
so
it's hard because we don't we obviously
the game tonight but
I would normally pick the bills as much
as I hate picking the bills because I'm
a Patriots fan
right now they're giving nine and a half
so they don't something that we don't
know
next game Indianapolis away playing in
Houston giving the Texans one and a half
points
I think in the based on yesterday
I know that the new Texans quarterback
is supposed to be good they're both
rookies
but I like I like and like everything do
you ever read the articles like I love
reading articles like about football and
they've been saying like the new
Indianapolis quarterback is like first
and first out like they just I don't
know something about quarterbacks like I
like reading articles to like get into
like their psych I feel like they need
like that kind of their personality
plays a role to me let me tell you
something not to interrupt you uh we're
on whatever game here last Saturday I
didn't know
the UFC was on whatever I think by that
time I had found out I came home and I
was uh
gonna show Mercy a clip of a movie
I was looking for a clip from Pee-wee's
Big Adventure when he rolls off on the
motorcycle and tequila
but when I clicked on YouTube it was Joe
Rogan in those guys okay
and uh I didn't get it so
Mercy ran upstairs and I was watching
Joe and those guys
and it came up to this
this is what I didn't tell you it came
up to the other Sanyo fight
and everybody in the room was like oh my
God all the Sanyo was the goat I was
getting pissed off at that because
Anderson Silva's the goat okay
and you know I saw Anderson Silva coming
through a UFC and just kicked a
out of like nine people in a row so
in my world it's Anderson so I'm
steaming already
the goat and I'm like you know what I'm
gonna throw an extra 20 on this
because even these guys are
talking about how this Sanyo and sure
enough
sometimes I like reading articles but
sometimes I don't and whatever I feel on
Tuesday
like when I woke up yesterday
Jacksonville the line dropped to four
from four and a half on Tuesday when we
did the podcast the week before uh at
first I didn't like it I go
I like them on Tuesday I like them today
and sure enough they came back and won
or whatever the it was you know so
sometimes I look a lot at lines guys I
don't know about the stats
I don't know nothing so you didn't give
me the Indianapolis Houston Texas I
think it's going to be Indy I think Indy
is going to win okay look at this game
here the Rams lose yesterday yeah I'm
almost positive no no no no no they won
I'm sorry okay
they're getting eight points from San
Francisco in Los Angeles
oh yeah I think San Francisco is going
to destroy Illinois I mean the Giants
lost 40 to nothing
and they give them four points to
Arizona in Arizona
yeah the Jets play the Cowboys let's see
if the Cowboys kicked the out of
two New York teams in one two weeks
for the Jets
it'll be interesting to see how they go
tonight
did you watch uh
the HBO show Hard Knocks with the Jets
at all this year no you know I only
watch like an episode and a half I can't
watch the whole thing but I I like to
you don't like watching that stuff
it depends who it is
is there a player who you'd watch right
now if like there was a certain team
right now that you'd like to watch
I like Jacksonville
okay
I like to see more Baltimore
would be really fun
Detroit is a good team to watch like you
know these are all teams that you catch
them now I'm not saying the choice
wouldn't win the Super Bowl but if they
keep playing how they were playing they
had to comeback kid so
I would have loved to have seen Ray like
the Ray Lewis Ed Reed Baltimore Ravens
like that like that oh my God good
defense it's like watching the Lawrence
tale of days it's like watching the uh
the Jack Lambert Jack ham days just just
great it was like a watch in an
opera it's like watching ballet the
way they move and you got
Denver at home against the Washington
commanders and Denver is given two and a
half
three and a half I'm sorry
the commanders aren't supposed to be
that good I think they won yesterday
I just think and I don't it's me I don't
know how it happened so quickly
but it seems like Russell Wilson and
granted I can't even pick up a football
with one hand but it seems like he is
he's shitty now for whatever reason
Russell Wilson Miami given two and a
half to New England at home
I don't I like you know what last year
and I know it's hard to listen to a
Patriots fan complain but it's I feel
like a hot girl that like isn't hot
anymore because it was awesome being a
Patriots fan for 20 years and it sucked
and I still think we're gonna be in
every game
this I thought our defense was pretty
good yesterday and it's just the
penalties which I Bill Belichick's been
great I think he sucks as a general
manager he's he's good on defense but
nikhil Harry speaking of which that he
just is not has not been great on
offense but I think I I want everything
in me wants to pick the Patriots to win
but seeing what they did to San Diego
yesterday
I think they're gonna yeah I think
Miami's gonna run all over the past and
I don't want them to
but Tyree kills a thousand miles an hour
I don't know how you I don't know how
you covered Tyree kill me neither did he
have two touchdowns yesterday yeah at
least two touchdowns 11 receptions eight
million yards a little game that got
they got great receivers
and if they could protect Tula you know
I I live around the corner from the the
biggest Miami Dolphin family they're not
even a a guy it's a family and
they show up and they bring food and
booze and and it's very and you learn a
lot because I remember in La I never
watched football now I go over there
that's my favorite thing they talk they
say it's tremendous I I
it's one of my biggest enjoyments and
guess what Lee I don't have to say
I'm stoned and I just giggle oh there's
so much fun I only went it was great and
I know it's only a joke but like it was
all of them but then they had like one
or two sons who are jets fans and they
had like them sitting upstairs by
themselves I mean while there's a party
going on downstairs you want to be down
there listening to that they just want
to focus he's got like three PVS going
you want to be by yourself they got a
room by yourself they got a living room
where you can watch like the Dallas game
let's say you don't want to watch Miami
and then they have the main room
downstairs and it is uh
I think I speak for everybody who comes
on Sundays they're all happy it's back I
didn't eat yesterday but that pizza
shrimp chicken wings chips every type of
beer you know he redid the bar I mean
uh I bring the reefer
you know I'm not surprised there's like
two guys who get high there we go
outside and smoke a little bit you know
I'm starting to do what I did as a kid
again and that's been great you
know I like I like sports Lee
but when you're married to something
right like you are about to be and I was
to really get into the nuts and bolts
I've been talking a lot on the Patriot
on the patreon podcast
about how much goes into our minds
that we think about and all that energy
takes away from your goals
you know Rogan always talks about oh you
got really funny I tell you what
happened I stopped dating a girl
the girl was a lot of work
a lot of thought
she came with me to the shows I don't
like women come with me to a show and
sitting in the back like Onassis I don't
like that I'm alone Soldier
you know I'm a lone wolf dog who's
Onassis uh whatever the Jackie
Onassis she was married to Kennedy and
she married Onassis
you know what she wants her and I
stopped dating
she took so much of my energy
with
that I had time to focus and I'm telling
you that I see so many people
who focus on the littlest
but they're not focusing on the most
important thing and at the end of the
day what they're focusing on doesn't
matter and I did it for years
until one day I said these
it's got nothing to do with me none of
those stories on the front page of the
Daily News has anything to do with me
unless I want them to unless I want to
read that and carry it all days you
know I see people who are obsessed
or hate Trump
you know just all they do I taste a lot
of energy out of you yeah at the end of
the day Trump being president not being
present doesn't even affect you
you're a bum you hear you're on
disability
you know you slip 20 years ago you don't
want to go to work but you know it's
just it's just Insanity so every time
you waste your energies on like
it takes away
from your main focus which is the prize
one of my son Swami from salami no I'm
just it's like a low because like you
know I think that and it's not even
limited to Comedy there's tons of people
chasing their dreams out there
but to like get out of like you know
relationship or quit a day job or to
move away from like family
like it's
like it's hard to do some of the things
you're talking like to really like just
throw yourself into something
it's a big decision I think I
see
you know I see people who are really
good at real estate
like right now if you sell real estate
it's a little rough right now with the
interest rates and the this and
that and the Low House inventory guess
what happens now
this is when the real salesman come out
this is when the real salesmen come out
when there's nothing
these guys are still selling Shacks for
and other people like what's
going on I can't wait Saturday they go
to my husband's party that's what's
going on
you're not and this is life you know
cars right now you know you go on to buy
a car you're paying all the dough for it
that they don't give a there's
other people you won't pay don't pay you
know
what was I talking about I don't even
about about making that decision
to like just go for it just go if if you
and I sit here about a club owner
and talk about how much of a douchebag
is for 30 minutes
we're not accomplishing nothing
right that's 30 minutes you and I could
be talking about a joke one particular
joke let's belt this out
till whatever and you call me about one
of your jokes I call you when I'm stuck
with one of your jokes you know
it's so weird how
even to see my daughter and my wife the
other day they went to kickboxing
and I asked her how was class and my
daughter's like it was great there was
only eight people there but Joey was
there Joey's one of her friends a girl
and I'm like really how is the brother
that a trip to both of them
and she's like he was great and my
wife's like well
he wasn't there and Mercy's like yes he
was you didn't see him he didn't have
glasses on but my wife was like yeah but
I sat with the grandmother and I still
didn't see him mercy and I'm like knock
it off six minutes does it matter if he
was there or he wasn't and this
is America
this is life people focus on that little
thing right Chop on it and the
whole time the world is moving
the world is moving
but like that that's a whole nother
because I love that I love
when we'll be out
and some a conversation won't start to
happen that has like really nothing like
you know it's like it's a small talk
conversation
but it's like they drive you nuts oh
there's a restaurant I go to that every
time this waitress is there I just want
to take the knife and stick it in my eye
and I love the place and I like her
she's very sweet and cute but she
doesn't understand that when I walk into
a place give me five minutes
give me five minutes to sit down
get my water look around see how the
wind is blowing and then I'll talk to
you for 10 10 hours but give me five
minutes I'm not even at my table and
she's already asking me how my week was
and I know she means well but knock it
off
come here every week just talk to me
about you what's going on you get some
dick last week what did you do you know
have you said this to her no because she
drives me crazy but eventually I'm going
to say something to her
because it's like eight minutes of
Chit Chat I'm starvingly
when I write a single place listen I
already know what I want to order when
that way you know tell them when the
waiter comes he's like would you guys
like something to drink yeah but we're
ready to put an order in oh yeah look at
me like are you crazy we just got dog I
already looked on the menu on the way
over here you really should have I'm
prepared yeah I'm prepared when I walk
in there because you don't know when
he's coming back like tonight I went to
the diner just to get maybe like a steak
on Monday night she has a good grilled
steak with onions and okay it's
pretty good
and she had the beef stew
and that's easy
and that's what I've been craving
Okay so
what are we talking about
we're talking
[Laughter]
[Music]
we were talking about hold on
oh God about um
those epx are good those ABX is a
real good no more than Tom
Segura
we were talking about a couple
different things about like making the
choice to to go for it and then you were
talking about I don't know how we got to
diners
diners drives and Automobiles
give me a picks for next week
if you were gonna bid a one pick if you
were gonna bet a hundred dollars
a yardstick who would it be an entire
week out but I'm gonna go Kansas City
plus three I don't think they're gonna
lose
two weeks in a row but if they do it's
gonna be a close game
I'm going with Jacksonville plus to
three
I think I don't think I don't think
that's possible you can add three points
to it Jacksonville isn't the one I saw
was minus three for Jacksonville
no Sunday September 17th Kansas City
minus three
Kansas City Monastery right now yeah oh
that's not plus three okay because what
I'm talking about and their Home
Jacksonville I'm gonna go with
Jacksonville for the upset
though
where are you at this week what do you
got Saratoga uh Comedy Works one show
Friday would these people want to go see
it open mike stock
I want them to go see it open mics to
see you from the beginning so they can
all say I know Lee syat when
all right uh the open likes Tuesday
nights I'm usually at Ralph's in
Worcester uh Wednesday nights there's a
great one there's a couple good ones uh
one at Blackstone and Worcester and one
at um Rick's in wound socket Thursday
nights is at the hotel Vernon it was a
great Open Mic there's a great night
Open Mic Monday night the best where
someone gets stabbed there's a fun
little scene out here in Worcester I
love clubs if somebody got stabbed or
somebody got killed the week before and
there's candles in front of the
collection just to protect my stand-up
it adds a different place there
are there are candles at this club and
it wasn't it's since changed only the
owners now were very nice it was before
it was best there were stabbings but the
candles are still there
so so yeah that's that's pretty much my
week we didn't uh
we didn't uh really discuss finish them
Danny Masterson thing okay the point was
my point was that those guys were really
cute
and uh they thought they were invincible
and I think this is a personal assault
on Scientology
you know I think that the word got out
these guys are intimidating people and
blah blah blah he's not in jail yet
no I don't think so I think he's out on
bond till he surrenders himself that's
what happens when you have money they
let they took me right there in the
Department didn't even let me go
back for a to smoke a joint is
doing anything so I can't believe the
Valentine went 30 years out of that
Court that's crazy
yeah I mean listen man uh it's so funny
when like right now I'm seeing like
remember during the pandemic during the
pandemic the world's in shock people
don't know what's going on and all of a
sudden people started talking about
charges
like this guy did this to me this woman
did this this guy did this and now some
people started getting canceled you know
what's so weird right now
it's one of the worst times ever for the
entertainment business
one of the worst times ever we're going
on a four-month strike you lived in L.A
I lived in La you know where we live
nothing moves without entertainment in
our area not even Yum Yum Donuts is
doing good even Yum Yum Donuts got
affected that chicken she had to point a
bicycle the little Mexican chick Vivian
from El Rancho wherever she
comes up from
you know everybody I feel bad for them
we spoke about this last week yeah now
in the middle of all this have you
noticed what's happening no day
attacking uh the guy on NBC the drunk
you know the the talk show host he's a
drunk people know he's got he's an
alcoholic he's a great guy Jimmy Fallon
oh he's not gonna say his name oh boy
he's one of those guys that drinks all
day he has to sleep in the afternoon he
has take a nap like Bert you know
I ain't mad at you I smoked up all day I
was eating Edibles all day I
can't but
it's just insane man
it doesn't say what happens to people I
mean it's not they're just pulling
people down like again
like that are in the entertainment
business
right now is not the time the strike is
killing and now is when
the and those that
open their mouth they ain't got a job
once the strike is over they better
start getting the job right now all the
people in Jimmy Fallon's because I
wouldn't bring him back we're a
family
I pay you we work together we work
12-hour days you know what
happens when you work 12 hour days with
people you see the worst part of them at
the eight hours I've been there I've
thrown fifths one time I was in a room
for 10 hours they didn't know I was
there I went I shot at 11 o'clock and
they came back and got me I shot at one
in the afternoon they told me go to your
room for a half hour we'll come and get
you they didn't even check on me till 10
o'clock at night
oh I'm back there high as well I
think it's gonna be eating
Edibles you know attacking the crab
service you know while it was happening
I wasn't mad but I'm gonna say when they
came in at 10 30 I was angry you
know I'm like what the guys so what
do you expect
when you work 12 14 hour days man
there's gonna be there's gonna
be some there's gonna be problems
you and I are not gonna agree on
everything
we're trying to make the best show they
can possible
do you remember like within the last 10
years there was an article because a
bunch of uh SNL interns
like sued the company yeah saying like
they were like they were interns like
they made them like pee in bottles like
and like they couldn't take breaks
and like everyone in the hours it was
before I even met you I think like
everyone in the office was like oh well
they're not gonna like just regular
post-production people are like well
they're not gonna get high you can't
you can't do stuff like that even if
you're because there are a bunch of
creepy people doing shitty things in the
entertainment industry
and I'm not like obviously if you get
assaulted you should tell people
but if someone's just like kind of a
dick
and it doesn't make it right at all
because I met some shitty people in L.A
no exactly on that they give a green
light to those
and make it act that way all the time
but yeah but there is something like
this people being too sensitive I think
well people are sensitive and then
there's there's some actors that are
unbearable
that are unbearable someone don't wear
deodorant
some come in and they're in character
and they think it's fine you know to be
what's the other guy the black guy that
was in trouble from all the
horror movies he got in trouble for
domestic violence
but everybody attacked him while he was
going through that saying that he was a
problem on the set
I've been on movie sex with the Stars or
just nightmares
and I've been on movie sets where the
stars are Dynamite
I've been told before like don't look at
like this actors coming in don't look
him in the eye like I've been told that
on a couple places they told me not to
shake or make eye contact with Bill
Maher they told me it's Sebastian and I
Look to Sebastian and about an hour
later Bill Maher came in and I go
Sebastian watched this and I walked
right up to Biltmore shook his hand and
gave him a hug he just I was
like 400 pounds he was gonna die he
wasn't gonna say hey man get off me I
just hugged him and you could feel them
just freeze the germaphobe
it happens you gotta bust that boss too
what's the worst to fight
I love putting this for you again this
is great I gotta go this game is
starting in five minutes oh let's
do it let's do it thank you what do you
think dude who do you think real quick
Jets or bills
you know
I think I'm gonna go with the bills
tonight well good I'm going with the
Jets let's see what happens all right
see you next week we'll talk
during the week all right
and now for a worth my
sponsored
[Music]
foreign
pipe for the smoothest coldest way to
smoke you got to try the freezable pipe
bubbler or bung from freeze pipe here's
how it works you pop the glycerin
chamber in the freezer wait an hour and
watch as the smoke is cooled by a
whopping 300 degrees no more coughing no
more burning I love the freeze pipe they
just sent me a new compartment for
blunts
guys you put in the freezer you roll
your blunt you take it out of the
freezer and now the blunts won't burn
you that bad they just released the mini
bong and a tornado bong and they're not
only affordable but the punch well above
their weight class and for those who
prefer smoking joints blumps and Vapes
free freeze pipe has you covered with
that new glycerin blunt tip it brings
your icy glycerin coldness when smoking
any type of joint blunt or vape say
goodbye to hard smoke and coughing
attacks by shopping in the smoothest
pipes bubblers and bongs and dab rigs at
thefreeze pipe.com and use code Diaz
Diaz for 10 off your entire order that's
thefreeze pipe.com code Diaz Diaz for 10
off shop today and start smoking like
you're living in Aspen
the checking is also brought to you by
Babel listen if you're headed to a
different country you need to pack
Babble in your suitcase Joey what's
Babble Babble is a real language
learning for real conversations you can
start speaking a new language in just
three weeks with that new fun 10 minute
sessions how great is that now you can
talk to people in different languages
who's better than you the program is
designed by over 150 language experts
with a conversation Based Teaching model
you'll be learning things you actually
need to know for real life situations
like where is the bus
stuff like that instead of fooling
yourself with language apps that are a
little more than games choose Babel b a
b b e l a study even found that you was
in Babel for just 15 hours is equivalent
to a full semester in college how's that
one for you here's a special limited
time for our listeners to get you
started get 55 off again
55 off Babel subscription but only for
our listeners at babel.com
Joey again that's babble.com Joey get 55
off at babel.com
Joey spell Babble
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Joey